es ist mal wieder soweit schneidet eure
gehirnzellen andern ich reagiert zum
dritten mal auf die serie to how to
handle meiner letzten weg schon auf
diese serie waren wir da stehen
geblieben dass diese beiden leute was
miteinander hatten da bin ich jetzt mal
gespannt wie es weiter geht nichts ahnen
von der bevorstehenden der hybrid sind
sich die mädchen für den abend auf
die hübschen wochen am längsten und
harry öffnet sich den jungs ein bisschen
zu sehr lieben sich die frauen nachdem
sich hier geht das so weil ich ein
beziehungs was ist das denn
es ist der perfekte deine beziehung
nicht zu groß nicht zu klein und hübsch
anzusehen
[Musik]
der start war direkt wieder mit voller
kraft
sie rauchen dies ist eine lockere runde
das muss man sagen oder kommen die
mädels müssen die lampe bandleader der
städtische räume schon wieder nackt alle
alle tanzen darum r fliegt wie ein
cooler urlaub aber die haben immer noch
das verbot am start
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bei einem kleinen spiel
[Musik]
was was
warte mal ganz kurz also eine person
stellt sich immer in die mitte muss ich
seine brille aufsetzen und dann dürfen
die anderen person mit der version macht
was man will und die lampe an der
direkte griff
okay was du dort wo lisa sie als traurig
vielen dank
er hat nicht mal an mich gedacht auch
die beiden hübschen hause gekommen
[Musik]
oh mein gott was ist was geht denn da
die beiden was machen jetzt die
küchenhelfer drücken die haben auch
schon geküsst
die maske abnehmen ich geh aufs ganze
und lasst ihr jungs wissen dass
francesca
[Musik]
ich würde gerne harry steht natürlich
auf die perfekte francesca die lampe
credit card area radio
ich muss dir viel zu häufig wir müssen
jetzt ein bisschen weiter gucken der
kuss war magisch das ist magisch
harry gar nicht rugby geschrieben herz
sein aber mal ran da denn jana spuckt
euch gehörig in diesem okay ich bin echt
gespannt ob die noch was haben bevor
jetzt dieses verbot kommt noch 45
minuten nur noch über ok oh warte was
vor der ersten nacht kommt schon das
verbot jetzt müsst ihr euch aber anhalt
mädels und jungs und lampen
während der rest der mädels sich
umstylen nutzt von chester den moment um
sich ihren mann zu schnappen
ja
hey
so still
ich habe die gleichen schuhe beschäftigt
wurde in köln falls sie war irgendwie
erinnern wartet so schnell die franziska
ist so unglaublich schön
ja
dem ist nichts hinzuzufügen
ich komme hier
ist halt immer
die kennen sich nicht mal seit einem tag
die sind da wie heilige tiger einfach
und überall sind kamera
[Musik]
nein sagt doch jetzt nicht genau in dem
moment wo davon ceska und harry sich so
ein bisschen blödes timing nennt man das
bei uns hier im inya das nennt man
überall so haben wir ein codewort gesagt
wahrscheinlich bei denen gibt es auch
anders handhabt willkommen zu ihrer
ersten nacht im resort selbst für eine
kew mich seid ihr alle ästhetisch
äußerst ansprechend
[Musik]
der günstigste diesel erklärt franziska
witte begebt euch nun zum palla okay was
ist das nicht toll apa die beiden die
beiden
ich hoffe das wird uns neue die nächsten
zwölf stunden walla im spionage modus
daten über unsere singles gesamte so
komisch was kommt jetzt achter steht
jetzt mit lord die beiden sind schon süß
zusammen schöner wäre es wenn es so
aussehen würde fündig willkommen im
dschungel
meine damen und herren
irgendwie will jeder was mit francesca
oder mit lana haben es wird interessant
in den letzten 12 stunden habe ich euch
und euer verhalten beobachtet das war
äußerst aufschlussreiche ja wirklich
schräg die steht ja auf einem geraden
ihr alle wurde ausgewählt weil ihr
bedeutungslose affären auf richtigen
beziehungen vor ziegen höher sind dieser
übung ist es euch zu helfen tiefere
emotionale bindungen in euren
persönlichen beziehungen herzustellen
die freundschaften mit frauen genau
freundschaften mit frauen als anreiz für
eure teilnahme dient das preisgeld von
100.000 euro
[Musik]
so würde ich auch gucken harry
[Applaus]
sie freut sich jetzt alle aber die wird
selber nicht was sie dafür machen müssen
wenn ich gewinne lasse ich mir die nase
operieren kennt sie wie wärs mit dem
neuen tattoo auf seiner nase was du dann
wieder nicht lesen kannst was müssen sie
dafür schon jetzt kommt mit dem geld tun
warum reagiere ich auf diese serie warum
kam ich auf die idee mir freiwillig pure
dummheit an zu tun was man das macht ja
auch nicht wenn ihr euch meine videos
anschaut
wir brauchen stangen der musik das ist
jetzt geht's los ich hab schiss die
klambt schon schwer ist die eigentlich
noch mal das ist diese typische die nie
was sagt in der klasse und dann
irgendwann muss man ihr müsst für ihren
gesamten aufenthalt behandlungen
entsagen
[Musik]
da wir jetzt wollen die smidt-arena aber
ich bin körperlich den den bonnern
deinen kopf in hessen sind jetzt geht es
hier los ist
im monat halte ich nicht aus ich dachte
die sind vielleicht zwei wochen oder
sogar nicht mal knutschen nach vorne
doch sie jeglicher art krake krank krank
je mehr ich darüber nachdenke desto
größer ist das prinzip von dieser schau
also die wollen diesen leuten die sonst
immer nur belanglose affären hatten
beibringen joh
wie wär's mal mit was richtigem das hand
und fuß hat
okay was hand und fuß hat das hat sich
jetzt sehr komisch an in diesem
zusammenhang aber ihr wisst was ich
meine
das gilt auch für selbstbefriedigung
[Musik]
wandl
das ist das erreichte zu dem level von
dem ich das erwarte ich das gewusst dass
ich mich heute noch nie so lange gar
keine action
ich bin ganz ehrlich ich kann mich auch
nicht daran erinnern wann das also
komplett ein monat lang gar nichts von
dem das habt ihr gut verstand ist
behandlung reduziert das preisgeld
das wussten noch nicht im blick sagt
eigentlich gerade alles krass willkommen
im resort
hi
ich bin luca und francesca an der stelle
ich das heute wieder ist allerdings
offen meine lieben freunde wenn euch
meine mittlerweile schon dritte reaktion
auf die urteile gefallen hat und ihr
unbedingt auch einen vierten teil haben
wollt dann lasst uns mit einem daumen
hoch unter dem video ihr da schreibt in
die kommentare was ihr denkt was noch
passieren wird bitte nicht spoilern
viele von euch haben die serie ja schon
gesehen allerdings befinden wir uns
jetzt auch im auto meine lieben freunde
und zwar könnt ihr hier oben einen kanal
abonnieren wenn ihr das tut dann
verpasse keine videos mehr unter anderem
auch nicht dann anscheinend meine vierte
reaktion auf diese serie denn das kommt
der mega gut bei euch an und hier ist
ein video verlinkt das leben auf meinen
zwei kanal online gegangen